i'll say this
there's no way in heck
that aaron is not going to be on the
packers i mean he's
he is uh
he's going to be the mvp of the league
might have had his best year ever he's
our unquestioned leader
and you know we're not idiots
we're not idiots is a great slogan for
really any sports team or other
organization
now that was mark murphy january 25 in
the aftermath of aaron rodgers making
that gratuitous right-hand turn at the
post-game press conference after the
packers lost to the buccaneers in the
nfc championship basically saying that
his future is in doubt as well as plenty
of others and made people wonder what he
was getting at well
the one thing that i believe that aaron
rodgers wants is security that he's not
on a year to your arrangement with the
packers and the easiest way to give him
that security is restructure his
contract in a way that would create a
prohibitive cap hit next year for
trading him and that would tie player
and team together for two more years so
murphy met with reporters yesterday and
was asked about aaron rodgers contract
chris
and he had nothing to say i can't get
into specific players we've been able to
create cap room with
others they tried three times
to get murphy to talk about rogers he
refused he refused he refused probably a
smart move because anything you say
canon will be used against you by aaron
rodgers so what i mean but what do you
what do you take away from that i mean i
know you have your own personal thoughts
i'd like to know them conspiracy mike or
reality mike i don't know where you're
at yet with this but well this is
this reality the packers have under the
contract that they entered into with
aaron rodgers they have now the luxury
of taking it a year at a time they've
got a guy they used a first-round pick
and actually used a fourth round pick to
bump up a few spots to get in jordan
love
they aren't just gonna flush him down
the commode because aaron rodgers was
the mvp in 2020 they're sticking with
rogers in 2021 because he was great in
2020 and if he's great in 2021 they'll
stick with him in 2022. if he's not
great in 21 if this is the year that the
slide begins and they decide after the
season it's time to go with jordan love
they've got the flexibility to do it
because the cap charged for trading
rogers before june 1 of 2022 is
manageable if they would have done the
maximum restructuring to get the maximum
cap space so they could go out and maybe
you know sign some players that would
help them win a super bowl this year it
would have resulted in the aaron rodgers
cap charge for trading him next year
being so great they couldn't have done
it would have been like 34 35 million
dollars i mean they could have done it
but it would have really hurt would have
been harder to do it and it would have
made it more likely aaron rodgers is
still on the team in 2022 that to me is
why they didn't do a restructuring with
rogers they want to have the flexibility
to continue to treat him as a
year-to-year employee and this is where
i think mark murphy is kind of a genius
yeah he knows that that'll piss off
aaron rodgers
and make it more likely he plays so well
in 21 that they'll want him in 22. well
yeah but you know the the the problem
with that too and and as far as 2021 is
you know you are rolling the dice on of
course you know
pissing off aaron rodgers sorry
liverpool but yeah
you you are and and the fact of you know
to the point where you know again
if the year goes down the way it goes
down and we still get into man there's
just not enough weapons around aaron
rodgers and things like that and he has
a good year who's to say he doesn't call
their bluff and say okay i've had enough
it's over or who's to say he won't he
won't they're banking on the fact that
he won't chris because he does not want
to be the villain i know he does not
want to be the bad guy and that's where
they're using his nature against him
right he never wants to be the guy who
comes out and says i want to go he's
pandered to the packers fans for years
and i don't mean pander in a pejorative
way he doesn't want to get the brett
favre treatment if he does leave he
wants it to be the team's fault not his
fault yeah well i think no matter what
he's going to be able to some to some
degree it'll look like the team's fault
that's where i just get into it and
you're right i mean maybe he won't do it
you know because of that i don't know
i'd also go like man people already have
their own thoughts about you aaron
rodgers you know if you look on social
media there's a lot out there that don't
love you and think you got all these
issues and everything like that anyways
so you know screw those people or that
you're worried about pandering to or
anything like that that's what i would
say to that but you know the other side
of this mic too is
i mean if he has here's the other thing
that you you risk a little bit he has
another year like he did this year 48
and five and as the nfl mvp and then
that conversation again
he he's gonna he can ask for a new
contract all together i mean we we know
that right now he'd be every bit within
his right to ask for more money and do
that so i i think he may be he may be
right right i mean he made it clear he
was gonna have the conversation i was
told he wants the contract because he
wants the security the restructuring
would have given him the security
without the packers having to give him
any more money but even
without the restructuring the guy's
making 33 and a half million on his
contract same as jared goff yeah and a
statement i'd love to argue that case
all i'd have to do your honor may it
please the court aaron rodgers 33.5
million jared goff 33.5 million see you
later that's it that's all you got to
say it is that's it is all you got to
say i mean if you named off a few other
people too that are ahead of them on
that list too you you know
you'd want to laugh to a degree uh i
mean carson wentz is right there with
them all that there's some people that
don't belong in that conversation
i mean again we know aaron rodgers going
to be the quarterback for the 2021
season but i i am very intrigued and
interested to see where this goes after
this year because there's there's a lot
of things that say trouble is on the
horizon or that there is going to be a
clash of
heads here between rogers and the
organization at some point and where
they they see the future going
let's take a break you look stupid too
if jordan love is sitting there for four
years in a row i mean at some point that
looks stupid too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports